David Halberstam author of the 50s who
was herb Stempel and Charles Van Doren
oh my goodness
they were almost one of the first
attempts of television to go to casting
and everything a shot the idea that
television everything it did had to be
cast and they were part of the great
quiz show scandal and what had happened
was that the the network was what Lee
the producers were looking for a wizkid
a kind of all you know a guy who could
answer every question and herb Stempel
was someone who had this brilliant mind
I mean he had sort of a encyclopedic
knowledge and he went on and he did very
well they tested him but he was by their
standards incredibly unattractive and so
they didn't know what to do they had a
kid who could answer all these questions
but there was nothing win about wouldn't
winning about him
so they decided to cast him as the
unlovable stemple and they cast against
him this great sign of a family the Van
Doren family a great literary family
Charles Van Doren and Van Doren was
elegant he was the son of a Pulitzer
prize-winning biographer the nephew of a
Pulitzer prize-winning biographer he had
grace he had just enough diffidence that
he made him seem made it particularly
attractive on television because he
never seemed to want it so much and the
whole nation fell in love with him it
was the first I think real sense to me
the important thing about Charles Van
Dorn is it shows what television could
do that it could take overnight someone
who had never been on television no one
knew his name and within 2 weeks make
him into a national hero someone who
could run for the presidency almost like
the Perot phenomenon and they did it
they brought Van Doren out and the whole
nation fell in love with him what year
was this 1957 I believe although the
scandal
I think breaks later on and the problem
is it's rigged so the country is falling
in love with Van Doren it wants van door
and graceful charming and
to beat the dreaded herb Stempel who is
considered to be sort of unattractive
lower-class for whatever and Van Doren
keeps winning and winning and winning
and what the country doesn't know is
that both stemple and Van Doren have
been given the answers to the questions
that it's all manipulated that it's a
fix the network was NBC programs title
was lesson 60 was 21 it was 21 but there
was a program called the $64,000
question it began it with the $64,000
question and then in the final
manifestation it was 21 with Van Doren
and stemple and a guy named dan Enright
as the fixer and the guy named Hal
Friedman as his sub sixer and it led to
congressional hearings on it in which
finally Van Doren who had protested his
innocence protested his innocence
protested in innocence had to go before
the country syan of this great family
and say what I did was wrong it was
rigged in fact a lot of my life has been
rigged and fixed there's a traumatic
moment for a lot of people while he was
it this is the end of innocence have we
corrupted everything I mean is there
anything left that is pure in America it
was a shattering moment for many
Americans particularly because that
Doren was an intellectual all-star
coming from that family with that charm
with a remarked sander and his father
was arguably one of the greatest
teachers and English professions of his
time and here was Charlie he was going
to follow in his footsteps and teach
English at Columbia and then was pulled
aside from a salary of 3,500 a year by
the promise of this enormous money in
this gate quiz show I noticed in the
back where you list all the people you
interviewed that you interviewed herb
Stempel but she did not interview
Charles Van Doren well I wrote him a
note I knew you know he's not available
for interviews and he has made that
pretty clear I think it's such a painful
thing in his life
that he's never quite come to terms with
it I wrote him a note saying listen I'd
like to interview you I think that what
happened with you is has a broader
resonance that really what it shows
is the television will cast everything
the president's a race for the
presidency television has to have
casting its drama
it isn't just politics has to be not
just politics but entertainment and I
think what happened with you and stemple
is the great first great example of it
and I got back very nice very polite
letter saying well I don't know if
you're right or not but I'm not giving
interviews there's a very polite letter
but it said nada and he moved to Chicago
and went to work for Mortimer Adler yeah
have Mortimer Adler with the great books
series was a family friend and he went
out there friend of mine saw him there I
asked a friend of mine who was an editor
of a Chicago paper what he was like
because in a city like Chicago the
journalists and writers tend to hang out
together I said was he part of your
group and he said no on a very rare
occasion I would see him and he struck
me as someone living in exile from
another country very sad phrase he would
write books that are still books of some
distinction but he cannot promote them
the way I'm promoting my book now
because he knew that if he went on any
kind of television show they wouldn't
ask about whatever book it is great
thoughts of the Western mind it would be
the first question would be what about
the quiz show scandal so he was never
able to promote his own books was the
twenty one program and the quiz show
scandal portent of what's we've gotten
since 1957 on television well I think it
was a reflection a of the power of the
medium on the country's much more
skeptical now there was an innocence
about television television was
brand-new anything that worked worked
and stunned people I mean there was sort
of you know when they first did the
$64,000 questions and was sponsored I
think by Revlon you couldn't buy a
Revlon product the next day I mean
Revlon doubled its percentage of the
market practically the other companies
that were in the same cosmetic field
went way down and in fact one of one of
the other companies had to write a
letter to its stockholders they you know
because of the extraordinary success of
our rival company with a quiz show our
stock went down this year it really
changed everything I think it was a
portent of how television cast
everything that there is it wants good
guys and bad guys 60 minutes which is
arguably a very good show but it's also
like a Western I mean there's Mike
Wallace wearing the white hat and
whoever he's interviewing he's got to
have a black hat on
I mean television loves that it doesn't
like complexity it likes simplicity good
and evil where do you live New York City
really near Lincoln Center in a lovely
apartment that was once designed for
artists it's a block called the Cafe de
Zarate Spa and the main room is
theatrical it's two floors and was sort
of little almost rabid war in other
rooms of it it's a wonderful privileged
life you know being a book writer I'm
about to be 60 and next birthday and I
go out and I write books I live a good
life and I I could have both my private
life and my professional life in a way
that an anchorman on television or a
superstar television reporter can't I
mean there's a wonderful level of
privacy and a wonderful level of
engagement in the society I have the
best of both worlds I counted in the
front of the book 12 books Plus this one
yeah 13 I think it is now and I've been
on a very nice role because I think oh
the last eight starting with the best
and the brightest have really all done
well I mean they made bestseller lists
and it's allowed me to have the the
ability to go out and write books and
sometimes four or five years sometimes
take four or five years like going in
and going to a university you'll enter a
door one day and then four years later
you come out you've sort of got your
intellectual degree from it and you've
learned so much more and yet you make
enough money to live in New York City
that's really that's very very lucky
were you born I was the born in the
Bronx my father was a doctor I'm my
brother and I were probably two years
younger then we should have been because
of the depression we're really
depression children he was more than 32
I was born in 34 and about the time that
our father was gonna make some money I
think he graduated my father was a
veteran of World War one he'd been a
poor kid immigrants son from small town
in Pennsylvania and about that he
graduated from medical school in 1929
and having been encouraged by the field
hospital doctors in World War one to go
back and study medicine that he could be
more than a medic and he graduated in 29
and he graduated in the depression about
the time he was finally gonna make some
money world war two came along at the
age of 46 he went back in the service so
we left New York and the Bronx then and
we we moved all over our our main home
from then on was a little town in
Northwest Connecticut a mill town called
Winstead I am one of the few people who
is known Ralph Nader since he was 8
years old when we were in the 4th 5th
6th 7th 8th grades together and we lived
in El Paso then we went from Winsted to
El Paso to follow follow my father then
to Austin Texas then to Rochester
Minnesota and I think it was I mean it
was difficult going to a new school all
the time but it also gave you a sense of
the size of the country and it allowed
me when I finally graduated from college
and went on to journalism to be more
fearless and more adventurous in the
assignments I took on you mentioned
Ralph Nader in your book in regard to
the Corvair but why did you write about
the Corvair in the 1950s well just as a
symbol of one of the things that the
book is about is it really says that
when you put down the book I wanted
people to know about the 50s but I also
wanted to know why the 60s happened when
you put down this book you should be
able to say yourself ah now I know why
the 60s happened and so by doing the
roots of the 60s I dealt lightly with
the coming of Ralph Nader and the
Corvair I mean the building of the
Corvair when GM begins to cheat just a
little on the roller bar the roll bar
when it it should have the balance and
for about $18 they take out something
that makes the car more stable you begin
to sense the power of the accountants on
a car that GM doesn't really want to do
anyway because it's a small car and it
thinks small cars small profits so he
cheats on this car as it shouldn't sheet
and out of that you get these terrible
lawsuits and these terrible terrible
accidents did some Americans resent that
little VW Beetle running around because
it was German
I don't think it was that it was German
I think when there was resentment of
things German post-war and there was I
mean in the early 50s you began there
was sort of anything German our
attitudes that were still some people
were still formed in World War two
anything German was bad I don't think
we're as tolerant yet the resentment was
more towards the mercedes-benz I mean it
wasn't towards a little a little dinky
bug like car I think the resentments
that the beetle brought were the
resentments of Detroit towards a car
that was small that didn't and and the
worst thing about the the beetle was
that the people were buying it could
afford Cadillacs that's what drove
Detroit crazy I mean the people who were
buying the beetle were these scientists
and college professors and they were the
affluent people of the upper-middle
class by all rights they should have at
least had a Buick and probably a
Cadillac and instead they're buying
miniature miniaturized transportation a
much smaller part of their budget and
instead they're going on skiing
vacations or going on vacation
to uh to Europe they're not using their
disposable income the way a good loyal
true American should back in the 1950s
which is to maximize their
transportation to have two or three of
the biggest cars you can get by the way
as you can see here a hold of that so
the camera yeah there is no index in
this book in order to find out what
cities yeah you got cheated there is an
indictable really yeah you've got
cheated I'm very sorry we will replace
this with a hand signed book and there
is an indirect they gave you a flawed
copy it probably makes it all the more
valuable problems that collectors the
collectors are you can probably auction
this book at a at an auction with your
notes on and probably be worth a great
deal I will personally get you a book
with an index it was maybe before the
day is out
it really wasn't complaining because it
forces a quickly to learn what's in the
book so you know what you really should
have an index book like this all right
forty chapters eight hundred pages seven
thirty in terms of the book the notes
the index the invisible index or the non
index and then the author's note to take
up another fifty or sixty pages i but
seventh we tried we wanted to bring
the book in at under 750 pages in terms
of the manuscript itself we had to cut
500 pages out my wonderful editor Doug
stump cut out and this was really stuff
that was good I mean it was a portrait
of Rocky Marciano as the last white
heavyweight fighter sort of rocky before
Rocky we had to cut it out
really good stuff what else was cut out
we cut out a section on cat the cat ran
dry as an early rebel we cut out longer
chunks of some of the stuff that made it
we just had to cut out a lot of really
good stuff you talk much about the
airplane anywhere there is some sense in
there I think of the jet airplane the
coming of the jet planes and we talk oh
I'll tell you one plane that is in there
which is brilliant as the YouTube I mean
here is this great spy plane that they
do almost door-to-door in 90 days I mean
from the time they in vision the idea
American science and technology and
error Aero and aeronautical engineering
is so good that from the time they have
the idea for a spy plane that can fly at
75,000 feet to the to the operative
model takes only three months you
couldn't do that today where were you in
1950 in 1950 I we had moved briefly back
to Westchester County I was still in a
school in New York we moved there
because my father come back from the war
and we briefly lived there 1951 I
graduate from high school in Westchester
the Korean War is on but my generation
we had we had an effect draft deferments
based on class in the Korean War without
anybody knowing it if you went to
college your draft board left you alone
no matter whether you were going to be a
scientist or not we were to ask so Korea
was the coming of a class line and who
fought for our country we didn't even
realize it at the time and so I had to
benefit of that and I went on public
high school kid to Harvard not a very
good student but editors the Harvard
Crimson managing editor and I graduated
in 1955 so I would so that I'm a child
of the fifties really when did you get
the idea for this book
well I've had it for a long time because
I really don't I wanted to do an autumn
biography but I don't think journalistic
autobiographies are any good I mean you
know there was someone says you know
writes a biography six presidents who
have known me and six presidents I have
known it turns out he hasn't known these
presidents very well and turns out you
know you be right about being overseas
in your overseas incarnation I was a
young reporter in the Congo I don't
really remember much about the Congo
except the difficulty I had filing from
the Telex and it's all it's not a clear
memory memo memo memory I don't have
clear memories of many Congolese from
now Zaire Ian's people so I think
journalistic memoir in the government I
did not know a general DeGaulle very
well and he'd he and I were not intimate
but I'd like to think that we had this
warm respectful relationship and one day
after one of his press conferences the
general came over to me signaled that he
wanted to talk and he said to me this
year best
I thought your question today was
beautifully phrased and your friends was
parfait that's your relationship with
General de Gaulle so this was a way of
doing an autobiography that which formed
me that which I lived through without
having to go through the boredom of my
own life did you select the way that the
book was laid out and the way the
chapters followed yeah I envisioned the
book six years ago another reason I
wanted to do it was that I though the
last long book I'd done was the
reckoning which was a story of the
American court economy coming under
pressure becoming vulnerable from
challenges from the challenge of the
Japanese and so I wanted to look at
America when it was rich in a world that
was poor when everything seemed to work
so these were the dual things and I had
a vision of the book about six or seven
years ago before I started out and it
was this vision I mean there would be
sections on television sections on the
affluence sections on the McCarthy
period and if possible near the end of
the book they would begin to twine
together they would as one person said
they would braid so that you would have
television and then he would have civil
rights and then late in the book
television
would be covering civil-rights that's
what I had I wanted to show the impact
among other things of television on the
society so that you get the speeding up
I mean I not only have General Motors
and it's pre math Lewis but late in the
book I have a wonderful chunk I think on
Jerry Schnitzer and Kensing or Jones
doing these astonishing commercials for
those Chevrolet's that are beautifully
done that are like Norman Rockwell going
to television it Chevy in the heart of
the American culture and so we have the
ability now to sell over television the
coming of this powerful instrument that
comes right into your home not just in
politics but as a salesperson and it's
and so I tried to I had that in my
vision that these that these different
parts would begin to braid together were
you working on any other book in the
middle of trying to do this yeah I did I
mean I think that book was that this
book was about six years long and in the
middle of it I did a small sports book
summer 49 which had great fun which was
by the way informed by this book because
this is a book on the coming of
television to the society and the summer
49 is on the last radio era in baseball
you know before big money before
television when you have these when you
hear a game on the radio and you form a
mythic vision of a DiMaggio or a
Williams they live larger because you
create the myth for the men in the
fantasy of your mind so that was a and
then I didn't others from I did that
book in the middle but I did a very
small book called the next century which
was an essay based on some of the things
that I had learned in doing the
reckoning of about America in jeopardy
why did you start in the first chapter
with a fairly long discussion about his
chambers Alger Hiss Whitaker chambers I
think it's the shadow of these a case
like that
and it was not just his chambers there
were a lot of things the Rosenbergs
Judith Coughlin what I wanted to show
was that here was America that was very
affluent in this post-war era Rich's
essay you know in a world that is poor
but the anxiety of living in a divided
world with the
communists at a time of nuclear weapons
where both sides have nuclear weapons
and then thermonuclear weapons and both
sides have delivery systems which is
even creates greater anxiety because the
things that have always protected us are
security blankets the two oceans no
longer matter because you can deliver
the ultimate weapon by jet or by rocket
the anxiety that causes an in addition
to what I wanted to show was that I
thought that the McCarthy period I think
this is if the book has in effect a
revolutionary idea and I don't know if
it's revolutionary but I believe from my
research that the McCarthy period begins
and gets into the virus a virus into the
bloodstream of the society when the
Republicans lose to Truman in 48 they've
lost four times to Roosevelt
they are chomping at the bit they are
already afraid that they are going to be
a permanent minority party but they
believe that Dewey will win when the
little haberdasher as they thought he
was and we know now is an extraordinary
American politician an extraordinary
American beats Dewey and they have lost
five times in a row the fear that they
are permanent minority party is very
real and in fact there is a very early
in the book I think it's about page four
I quote a meeting of Thomas T Dooley
going to see Dwight Eisenhower and
asking him to run because he is this
independent who's above politics and do
he is saying and he has Eisenhower's
notes of it you know a Republican can't
be elected anymore because the Democrats
demographically because if Roosevelt
have so changed the nation that you have
a plant in effect where they're 500
people five people are managers and they
wear suit and tie and they vote
Republican and 495 are blue-collar and
they're Democrats and they vote for the
Democrats the demographics are against
us it is this fear of being a permanent
minority party that I think begets the
McCarthy period because for the first
time they have to seize on another issue
you know the pure economic issues
they're a minority but if they seize on
this issue that is subversion and
government the
idea that our government has been soft
on the Communists or even hand-in-hand
with it that we have been subverted here
domestically by our own people that will
get them back in and that issue begins
only after duties does he do he runs a
very honorable campaign he does not use
smadi does not use the anti-communist it
does not use softness on communism that
stuff comes after his defeat and even as
someone as elegant as Robert a Taft
we've really not had many senators
better more elegant more distinguished
finally says to McCarthy Joe McCarthy
Joe keep going
if one case doesn't pan out try another
ie put the Democrats on the defensive
use this issue to keep them on the
defensive let me read this sentence the
setting was this August the 3rd 1948
House Committee which included a large
number of the most unattractive men in
American public life bigots racists
reactionaries and sheer buffoons held
hearings in which Whittaker Chambers not
only said that he himself was a
communist but that there was a communist
group in the government in the late 30s
and that Alger Hiss was a member of it I
mean let me just do that again bigots
racists reactionaries and sheer buffoons
were you talking about the house on
American Activities Committee that one
solid person on that committee was a
young congressman from California named
Richard Nixon I mean you just couldn't I
mean they were known for their
buffoonery Nixon was intelligent serious
smart he was by far the most reliable
member of the committee he was being fed
stuff by a J Edgar Hoover he had access
to the FBI files but he was and he
performed very skillfully in the kis
hearings I mean he did not by the way
have a bad press in the histories he
would later claim the press is against
me because of this that's not true
the press was against him finally for a
variety of other reasons but in his case
you really had a buffoon a bunch of
buffoons on that committee and when in
fact when when hiss made his first
presentation because he was so elegant
and so sophisticated the epitome of
Harvard Harvard Law School and the
establishment and chambers who was
brilliant but really
of disheveled man with a very bizarre
past most of the committee members had
let's get out of this thing that guy
this looks terrific
let's get rid Amin I don't like the look
of chambers they were saying it was only
Nixon and I think in part cause he was
being fed by the Hoover people he knew a
bit more than the others said no let's
stay on it and he noticed that there was
a nod there was a certain quality to his
to his denial that they were really kind
of calculated they were not complete
denials there were little phrases in
there that protected him from complete
denials and he pursued the case and more
and more stuff came out and it turned
out that you know two juries in effect
believed that chambers rather than his
was telling the truth I mean in the
first case you had a hung jury I think
it was eight to four for conviction of
perjury against his and the second jury
was voted to convict your hiss is still
alive I think he's still alive yes and
you write that even though last year
there was a spurt of information coming
out of the Soviet Union that suggested
that he might be innocent that that was
proven wrong also yes I think there was
there was what happened is Volk Agana of
lieutenant-general the head of the KGB
file sort of said Alger Hiss you know
you're we've checked it out in your free
man and then I then apparently he was
told to that by people representing his
that this was a very old man and he's
near death and it would be a wonderful
thing if he could let him go not knowing
that this was still a burning issue in
America so he did this and of course
nobody has really gone through all the
files the files are probably incoherent
and all over the place so he then having
started a firestorm of protest among the
ProTeam burrs antihistamine George will
and others wrote about it he backed down
very quickly and said that in fact he
had not had access to all the files
looking back from where you said what do
you think of the whole histories thing
well I think they're missing pieces
nobody really knows all I am inclined to
believe that his in
obviously he has new chambers despite
his denial
I am inclined to believe that either his
was a member of the Communist Party or
his protecting his wife who was I mean
there's something there there's just an
awful lot of stuff that is there that
doesn't go away I mean obviously as well
Chambers is incredibly conspiratorial
and living this life of the double age
and deep in his own paranoia but also a
brilliant man I don't think what was
made the case was made out to be in
effect the lesson for a generation as if
this would then symbolize the entire New
Deal and the end of the New Deal I don't
think it's a symbolic case but it was
made in this was made into a symbol
which I don't think he was one of the
things that you know it pops up in your
book periodically is how you often
mention along the way you say that
letter to chambers was a homosexual you
say later on they talk about Tennessee
Williams being in a public homosexual I
think Jack Kerouac and and I percentage
of the beach were but coming today
reading about this in 1993 this was back
in the 1950s was that an issue back then
well I think there was a lot of back
channel word about chambers and one of
the reasons that his credibility at the
time was relatively low was that they
had a lot of stuff in the file that
showed that his life you know had a had
a darker side and that's certainly for
someone like J Edgar Hoover made him a
less than perfect witness I mean Hoover
with his own homophobia was not going
about pin and he made Whittaker Chambers
was hardly a white knight to the people
who would have wanted him to be one I
mean he was there was a quality of so
much pain and anguish in his life that
they were weary of pinning their great
hopes on him intellectually as it turns
out and you can read them his book
witness is a brilliant mordant study of
human frailty Whittaker Chambers yes but
was a great book witness but let me ask
you about this so you talk about the
homophobia of Jogger Hoover then you
kind of refer to the fact that he and
Clyde Tolson were what well there was
this odd thing they were always together
they were
each other's best friends I mean I don't
think anything ever happened I don't
believe these stories you know that they
have now about Hoover dressing up and
drag I don't believe it for a minute i
mean j edgar Hoover's whole life was
devoted to getting dirty stuff gossip on
other people the last thing in the world
he was going to do was provide gossip
for his enemies I mean he just wasn't
going to do that but there was this odd
relationship between him and Tolson they
were together at every meal they went to
work together you know they ate alone
nobody else you know nobody else need
apply the two of them eating lunch and
dinner almost every day of their life I
mean it was an unusual friendship I mean
I don't think anything was consummated
but it really did make people talk about
them I'll come back to television in
politics in just a second if someone
were to follow you around over the last
six seven years and watch you put this
book together
what would they see I mean for instance
do you all these interviews you listen
to back do you go to them personally do
them on the phone where do you write
well I think most interviews should be
done personally I think it's great fun I
think you interview better when you see
someone I think they give you as you
show up you get a higher validation
you've made the effort to come to your
house you've seen people it's more fun
the fun is in doing the interviews and
so I mean you often do follow-up
interviews you know hey we see someone
hey I forgot to ask you such-and-such
they would see me go to the library hey
great deal for this and read books
where's that guy well in New York
there's a wonderful library that I love
going to called the New York society
library it's a small private library
79th between Park and Madison it's
wonderful it's not very expensive and
while I do go to the New York Public
Library there's something about the New
York society library that I really love
it
a friend of mine named Eli Zabar runs a
wonderful little food shop most
expensive food shop in America I mean
you know probably a roast beef sandwich
is about $200 these days but he is over
there at 80th 80th and 85th in Madison
so if I work till about 2:30 I often go
and have a light lunch and I get a
cappuccino there and then the you I will
come over and
walk with me so we have a very nice I
check in with a friend I had this great
cappuccino and a light lunch maybe a
couple salad and I've had five days five
hours in the library five hours in the
library is just wonderful I mean it's
always an adventure
it's like eating salted peanuts you
never know what you're gonna get next
what are you write I write at home my we
have a small in addition to our regular
part we have a very small apartment in
the back and my wife wanted to get me
out of the main house where I work
because she thought the steam and Hanks
that came out of my ears and nose and
during the day while I was working there
significantly detracted from her calm
and her control of space so we got this
back apartment which is really quite
nice and I go up there and I get up in
the morning when I'm writing if I write
in the morning and I get up and I have a
very lazy cappuccino I love the
cappuccino and very light breakfast and
I'm about 9:30 or so I go up to what I
call the cage which is where I write
I've got a nice little CD player
sometimes I play the blues or sometimes
it's mr. Vivaldi or mr. Mozart in there
and then I work for about five hours and
when it's done and there's some exercise
machines there and whatever and some
books and it's a nice place but when
it's done I want to get out of there and
Jean my wife says come on why don't you
you're gonna read why don't you read in
the office and I said it's a cage what
I'm in there and it's exhausted I'm
writing I'm writing everything I think
about in that office is writing the
moment my writing for the day is done I
want to get out I want to be here I want
to be with you or whatever I don't the
pressure of writing and being in that
room is so great that when it's over I
don't want to be in the room I can't
relax almost until I'm out of the room
what are you right on I used to be a an
old-fashioned typewriter on the back I
never went to an electric typewriter and
then about ten years ago friends can
Vince me to try word processors and it
has liberated me and probably doubled my
productivity I mean because it just it's
a great instrument with which to rewrite
you know to clean the old days
one typo and you typed it and to retype
the whole page because of a typo I make
a lot of typos I'm a fast hunt picking
pac-man I make a lot of typos now I just
it's like playing pacman cleaning up the
typos it's it's so it's really made my
life a lot easier and it's really damn
near doubled my productivity are you
already writing on another I'm gonna do
I've got two books I'm working on I'm
very excited about one it will be a you
know I did summer 49 and that's the
beginning of the Yankee dynasty and then
I'm gonna have a book on the Cardinals
and the Yankees in the World Series of
64 which is sort of the end of it and
the rise of a great st. Louis team with
Gibson and flood and Brock and McCarver
and white good characters and then I'm
gonna do a book I was a reporter in
Nashville Tennessee 33 years ago the
first sit-ins started there it was a
very interesting group of young black
kids I was the reporter from the then
liberal Tennessee which would cover
stories like this as a lot of newspapers
did not and it was triumphant terrifying
I mean the fear the violence whatever I
covered it I was a year older than they
were they came finally to trust me and
I've had friendships and associations
for example with John Lewis who was a
congressman Marion Barry was part of
that group and I want to track their
lives then and now I think it's gonna be
a wonderful book John Seigenthaler Al
Gore lots of other name of it this
Westfeldt is a great paper
it was a great I stroll town of
Nashville Tennessee and I'd worked for a
year in Mississippi I got out of college
in 1955 and I had been managing there at
the Harvard Crimson and I wanted to be a
journalist really badly but I often you
know and I'd you know you're managing
out of the Harvard Crimson that's this
year and that's pretty good that's
you're putting out a paper six times a
week for very sophisticated audience but
I knew I was incomplete I knew I didn't
know enough about talking to people I
had to learn how to go out and interview
ordinary people I had to do an
apprenticeship I decided this myself
because I think I could have gotten a
job in New York or Washington and if I
was going to do is a year after Brown
versus Board of Education if I was going
to do an apprenticeship why not do it in
the south why not in the deep south
why not in Mississippi which was the
the deep south the most recalcitrant
state and there was a guy at Harvard
named Tom cárcel who was a Nieman cell
you know a 35 year old journalist and he
said he was going to be the editor of
this new liberal paper in Jackson and he
said he'd hire me
terrific everybody we graduate all my
other friends on the Crimson are going
off to Rhodes Scholarships or different
fellowships I'm going to where I'm going
to Mississippi I get down there he's not
working for the new liberal paper he's
working for the old racist paper the
Jackson Daily News I've got everything I
own packed in my 46 Chevy what do I do
they find me a job as one reporter on
the smallest daily in the state of
Mississippi the West Point Mississippi
Daily Times leader and I go there and I
work 46 dollars a week 45 plus a dollar
because I X trakone is club every
Wednesday greatest experience probably
of my life fresh out of Harvard Jewish
you want to be in a different
environment my friend you are in a
different environment and I learned a
lot I learned how to deal with ordinary
people to listen to them to see people
the value with people who didn't didn't
agree with the same things that I agreed
and how they work what their lives were
and from there I went to four wonderful
years on the Nashville Tennessean again
honing my skills learning to interview
people I looked around I knew I wasn't
as good a leg man digging so I figured
out who the good reporters on The
Tennessean were and I just watched them
every day and every night
I went out to dinner with him I think
how did you do that how did you do that
when I got out of there after that five
year apprenticeship I was a really good
reporter I mean everything had come
together for me for those people who
want to know whether they should buy
this book if you don't mind I want to
tick off a lot of different names and
give just 30 seconds and then they can
get the rest of it but there's so much
that it might be helpful uh Betty
Furness
she's wonderful she was the Westinghouse
lady she'd been a B actress was doing
some out in Hollywood was doing some
small television work in New York she
watched the coming of early television
they had all these people who couldn't
were trying to display their things
couldn't do it she became the letti the
lady from Westing
she's smart attractive women liked her
men liked it but women liked her as well
you could almost chart the coming of the
super appliance it begins she's twice as
big as the refrigerator then year by
year in the 50s the refrigerator sort of
begins bigger and bigger it gets bigger
and bigger and Dwarfs her she would go
out to do the conventions in 52 and 56
and they had to do stuff live
she'd have 60 different outfits that
she'd keep changing so that she would
never look boring and she became as
famous as Walter Cronkite as anybody on
those shows and she is a lovely lady and
what television caught about her was
that she was nice and it wasn't by
mistake that men liked her and women
didn't feel threatened by her because
she's a good person
Alfred Kenzi great American
distinguished scientist ultimate square
the square is man a professor of zoology
I mean a man who had the greatest
collection of bugs midway in his career
his students come to him and say we
don't really know much about sex so he
starts giving a course on sexuality and
it becomes the most you know because
it's a great guarded secret in the 40s
and suddenly it's the most popular
course at Indiana University and with
that knowing that these students don't
know the most elemental things about sex
he gets into interested in sexual
studies and he begins to do these
classic studies of sexuality which I
mean taking them out the darkest subject
covered with the most superstition and
trying to ventilate it what are our what
are our sexual habits you know what do
we really do how much experience have we
had and he publishes first the sexual
habits of the American male and then
later the female and is pilloried for
having done a brilliant scientific study
instead of even I mean liberal ministers
heads of the universities like Princeton
attack him saying he should attack his
own findings I mean it's this is wrong I
mean he's publishing this stuff and it's
wrong he was a brilliant brilliant
scientist a truly revolutionary man
Betty Goldstein oh well that's the
maiden name of the lady who wrote
rather large on the decade to come her
name later became Betty Ford ad she was
bright summa [ __ ] laude went to Greenwich
Village was filled with the excitement
of being a young reporter in the village
then she marries begins to have children
is pulled to the suburbs and she's
suddenly beginning to wonder is this all
there is to my life in 1957 she starts
doing a study for her 15th reunion at
Smith
she starts sending out a questionnaire
to other people and she finds out from
all the other Smith women of this
generation that they share many of them
I won't say all many have the same
despair frustration and this question is
this all there is to life us sitting out
in the suburbs
driving station wagons taking care of
our children or is there going to be
something more how does that comes The
Feminine Mystique
a seminal book a couple of weeks ago
this lady died and you write a couple
pages on her I think Pat Nixon I think
she's heartbreaking she has a childhood
so harsh
it is Dickensian it is hard I mean as if
she lived in the time of Charles Dickens
she hard to imagine anybody was so
difficult to life and you know her
mother who's the one person she really
loves dies when she's young her father
dies she raises her brothers cooks for
them takes keeps house cleans and then
goes off and studies herself puts
herself through school I mean utterly
admirable really beautiful when she
young eventually marries Richard Nixon I
don't think she really at first when
they dated she was not that enthusiastic
about going on out with him but he was
nothing if not persistent and I think he
was the one way she could get out of
Whittier California and ask if this was
new information you're interviewed Jim
Bassett who was a press secretary to
Richard Nixon and you talk in in this
book about the fact that Richard Nixon
treated her differently in private than
in public is that no I don't I mean I
think it's been there before but I think
it's used in this book as I've brought
it out a little bit more in this book I
think you know I think from almost the
checkers speech on people were
astonished by how when they were in
public
she was the great prop to him she would
look up adoringly at him and but then
they would get back in the plane and it
said separately as if in two universes
and they would never touch and I think
when he had his farewell speech you know
when he was driven out because of
Watergate he talks about his mother at
great length his father at Great Lengths
and how you know in this very
sentimental moment what wonderful people
they were he never mentions her and
she's the person who's gone through more
agony because of his career than anyone
else I think I think she never wanted a
career in politics she wanted a nice
suburban life with the children with the
kind of middle-class affluence and
security that she had been denied
herself
did you see the funeral by the way I saw
just clips brief clips of it there was a
rather emotional former President Nixon
I just wondered if you had any sense as
to why after all these years he would be
so emotional in public over this I don't
know maybe it finally came home doing
how much she had given and how much a
higher price she had paid I think for
his career I mean I think there is she's
really fascinating she's a classic wife
of the fifty stoic do what your husband
wants even if it's not what you do go
along with it that's your role you would
not find many political wives like that
today
Ozzie and Harriet Ricky and David well
they're the symbol of America in the 50s
I mean when people talk about America in
the 50s and he talked about is an
innocent time they think of those early
shows Leave It to Beaver father knows
best
Ozzie and Harriet and they were the
all-american family and yet
the 50s were not that innocent I mean
even in this all-american family you
know no one knows what he does but he's
a good easy relaxed guy in real life
Ozzie was a workaholic quite
authoritarian really dictatorial wrote
directed and produced all these shows
used his own children in the shows I
mean and really in some ways you could
argue took away part of their childhood
particularly with Ricky took away the
one thing that really mattered his music
and put it into the show so that
you know your key I think was always
unhappy with that you could make the
argument that in the end the Nelsons
were something of a dysfunctional family
even though they were the ideal to all
those other American families back in
the 50s I saw Kemmons Wilson listed as
one person that you interviewed where
did you find him he's in Memphis
Tennessee still very much alive Holiday
Inns he drives in the early 50s he
drives to Washington from Memphis he's a
home builder with his wife and he's
annoyed because they've got a couple of
kids with them and everywhere they go
the motels are still pretty primitive
you have to check out the motel go is
that okay is it clean as or is it sleazy
as some hotels work want to be in those
days and then you have to pay a dollar
extra for each child and he's furious
and he vows to his wife when I get back
the first thing I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna go in business and build a chain
of 400 hotels and she said you know
you're just crazy he does it he and he's
a home builder so he knows how to build
something big which is that the cost is
you know in the plumbing and the windows
but if you make it big it's not that
much expect more expensive so he does
this he has a sketch he sketches it out
and architect friend looks at it
finishes it off and comes back with a
big sign that says Holiday Inn the
chemist says where'd you get that says
well I was watching the movies while I
was finishing I was watching this movie
you know Bing Crosby and so I put it on
there from that comes the Holiday Inn
chain with thousands of motels and he
becomes brilliant at going to every city
with a little plane and spotting the
entryways and where to put his motel
right on the outside at just the right
junction with just the right approach so
that the sign can be seen an American
genius an American original of all those
people that you track down at you list
in the back that you've interviewed
which one do you remember the most I
mean who are some of the interesting
characters I think bill 11 I mean here's
I mean you talk about the American
Revolution of affluence the coming of
this if we're taught this book is a
little bit about the century of the
ordinary man the common man with a
common man lives as the wealthy have
lived in the past I mean we take
middle-class affluence for granted today
but it wasn't always that way I mean but
it began in the fifth
never was there a country so rich and
never was there a country which shared
its wealth so equitably and probably the
great enabler of that signature figure
is build of it who does this
mass-produced housing I mean he's really
a lineal descendant of the first Henry
Ford who does mass-produced cars
assembly line cars and the worker for
the first time can buy a car the worker
as consumer build effort takes it a
second
an additional way he takes it into
mass-produced housing well you can't
have houses rolled down the assembly
line they're too big so he does
something different he brings the
workers to the site and the site is the
assembly line and then each day a
different group goes out and does one of
about twenty-one functions boom boom
boom 18 house is finished in the morning
18 house is finished in the afternoon a
hundred and eighty thousand and really
well-built finished at the end of a week
and they are good and they are sturdy
and that you can get them with a hundred
dollars down mr. veteran says the ad
you're a lucky guy with a hundred
dollars now and you can get a eleventh
house or did you find him I found him
with about four phone calls couldn't
find him couldn't find him finally a
lawyer friend of mine whom had worked
for him in the past found him I
interviewed him came by my home could
not have had a better day I think if
he's in if there's a hero in the book it
may be William love it I mean we are
talking about an era of affluence the
century of a common man where the
ordinary person has dignity affluence
and the fruits of his labor as has never
happened in the history of mankind other
societies have followed us Europe now
the Japanese now the beginning of it in
Korea but we were the first and one of
the great enablers is someone like Bill
Evans
how old is he god I think he's probably
in his early 80s now where does he live
he lives in Long Island who else anybody
else that day memorable I like the
McDonald brothers I think they're
wonderful these guys who haven't made
very much of a success in American life
and then one day they opened this little
place out in San Bernardino and they
began to do well but they begin to check
their menu out I mean they don't have I
don't have any computer but they start
checking out what works and they figure
out you know it's time to narrow the
menu nobody's buying the barbecue they
get rid of paper they get rid of plates
and silverware they get rid of the girls
the carhop girls because people stick
around too long for these pretty girls
and they begin to mechanize the process
of the American hamburger and the bigger
they become geniuses stainless steel
grills a stainless steel thing that you
can squirt ketchup just the right dollop
of ketchup out I mean they begin they
have a friend who's an inventor they
tell him their problems and he goes out
and does it and suddenly they have
assembly line hamburgers 15 cents and
they're making each is making $100,000 a
year and then Ray Kroc and the merit
another American genius comes and
decides to franchise it becomes their
franchisor and the McDonald's really
aren't very interested in franchising
they don't want more wealth they're very
happy with what they have are they alive
one is did you talk to yes I did Mac
McDonald yes it was wonderful to talk to
he's a wonderful man where'd you find
him he's up in New Hampshire the people
out at McDonald's helped let me find him
I thought is leverage man
I think he's got me no he said I could
have been a lot richer but if I were a
lot richer I'd have a lot more problems
I'd be up in the top floors of 40 40
storey building and I'd be surrounded by
nothing but tax lawyers and I don't want
that I made all the money I needed you
know they would they make about a
hundred thousand a year and the first
thing they did each year was what the in
those days the wealthiest man in every
town did he took his one-year-old
Cadillac
Plus $700 and turned it in for a brand
new Cadillac that's what you did in the
50s said we come back to television and
politics the Alger Hiss Whitaker
chambers hearings were televised but you
say this was the first national politics
that was the first of there's almost not
even national as a small network of
hookups I think New York Boston
Washington and Philadelphia the hissing
was really I don't know that it was
really televised in any real sense but
with this you had the first moment where
there's Frank Costello being accused of
being a mob guy and they had the camera
on him and he says I don't want the
camera
on me shall I put the camera on his hand
because he's had nodded you see they
were sweating I mean it is a dramatic
moment in the power of television this
is 1951 the next year Estes Kefauver is
a serious candidate for the presidential
nomination and you get a quick sense of
the power of television but did
television do for Richard Nixon well it
got him it kept his place on the ticket
when there was a slight scandal as a
fund some wealthy backers in California
had created for him the the alleges
flush father I think it was pretty small
goods but he was he had these charges
and suddenly there was I who had been
promised to clean up the corruption in
in Washington and he gives this idea of
a of a houndstooth Club that Nixon has
to be cleaner than a houndstooth and
with that Nixon defends himself in this
quite is in his speech the next of
checkers speech where he sort of says I
you know Pat has a cloth code and it's a
Republican cloth coat and she looked
good in anything it's quite a bit of
bathos in that and he sort of he opens
up their checkbook he says how poor they
are she who has fought this draconian
poverty hates it she hates the chequered
speech she hates revealing how poor
they've been and how hard their lives
have been but he wins his place back on
the ticket with this speech is that
where you write about the shave stick
that's no that's the Kennedy Nixon
debate where you know Nixon sort of like
I do has a very dark beard and a light
skin and he arrives in Chicago it's the
climactic moment of the book the end of
the decade and he's gonna debate John
Kennedy and there's a great question of
which you know will they use makeup and
Nixon neither wants to use makeup and
then find out the other guy hasn't used
it well unfortunately if it has a pale
skin dark beard and he looks sick anyway
because he's been ill his clothes hang
on him
Kennedy comes in and he looks wonderful
he's been out campaigning in California
so he has this great you know tan
and Nixon is very sensitive to light and
suddenly in the middle of the of the
debates the heat the you see rivers of
Commerce wet washing down the cosmetic
it's kind of a cosmetic meltdown on his
face and he in effect loses the
televised debate my friend Russ Baker
says it's the moment in America where
images replace words as the currency of
American politics and it it is and also
what he loses in this because you have
to remember when he goes into the debate
he's not only the famous vice president
and a famous debater because he's
debated Khrushchev earlier but he's been
vice president of the United States for
eight years so the one thing he has is
his great experience whereas Kennedy is
allegedly this young junior senator too
callow too young when it's over that
debate has brought Kennedy to peer
position we Nixon loses his eight years
of expertise as vice president in that
night and from then on he's fighting
defensively to stay out stay alive
haven't got much time so this has been
fun little things this isn't so little
really the thirteen books you've written
is there one that's sold more than all
the rest well I think this one's my
understand it has even as we're talk
it's number one on a bunch of lists and
I think it's the right book at the right
time and I mean I sort of sensed that
about a year ago when I saw the
wonderful response to David McCullough's
wonderful book on Truman I had a sense
that a book on the 50s was probably the
timing was going to be good hi there so
I have a small book that I did about
four young men growing for an Olympic
medal that I really loved you know when
you ask someone which of your books do
you prefer it's sort of like asking
somebody with a large family which of
your children you love the most but
sometimes in your family you have a
child that's not as big as the others
and not as famous and whatever but you
know that that child has the sweetest
heart and the little book I did call the
amateurs about these four young men
rowing is my interest my secret favorite
as you went about researching the 50s
and Charles Van Doren wouldn't talk to
you where there are others that you
would like to tour there a couple of
times I think
where I didn't get much response if
people didn't respond in some cases I
think they were very old I mean some of
the people who were players were in
their 80s but I think of it myself
generally as having very good access I
mean it's a lovely time in my life I
mean you you know you spend 3035 years
building a constituency and doing things
and suddenly it seemed to me that it all
came home with this book I mean I do a
section on the Emmett Till trial and the
coming of mass journalism at the Emmett
Till trial in 1955 and that's and that
was a section I've been trying to write
for some 35 years I as a young reporter
I tried to write a magazine piece about
all these reporters coming down to write
this to cover this trial and I didn't
have the skill to pull it off I finally
pull it off 35 years later 38 years
later in this book that's the best thing
in that last minute we've got that
somebody can come up to you and say
somebody you don't know and I assume you
get that all the time
what what what what when you walk away
from somebody just met you and they've
said things to you what's the best thing
things is I think if someone came up and
said listen I nee not only liked your
book but it made me understand better
where the country was then and in the
60s and more importantly why we have
some problems today
if someone says your book has informed
me and allowed me to understand where we
are as a country and what happened then
and why and why we have different
problems now then you think you you know
you're trying to be a part of an
informed society you're trying to help a
society know that it has a compass and
use that compass well and if I can be
part of finding true on the compass and
that's an ongoing struggle finding true
on the compass for society as large as
contentious as diverse as our as ours
then you've done your job well this is
that what the book looks like it's by
David Halberstam
and it's called the fifties thank you
very much sir